あっ
ガチの実験みたいになってきちゃったんですけどもこんにちははじめ社長ですチミ達
まぁねって知ってるかバネバネルというのはあれ施工3ターンがあると思ったの
4秒で跳ねる呼ばれるっていうのはチェコの説明いるからとりあえずバレー版映画貼り
ますねうニューって何とピュア女版出る場面があるんですけども
今回はそのバーに関する実験をしようと思います校
がいわれたでちょっとガッツにこんな装置みたいな方まで準備しちゃってるんですけど
もうなんとですねうんしたと言われる会社独自剃髪された特殊なゴムがあるんですけど
もう
こちらですねパワーバネというものでございますこちら伸縮線に優れた特殊なゴムで
すごいなんですけどももう番ゲみたいなもんなんですよ要するにバネの力を始めた
新しいゴムがムースターサンになっ
外したということでございますは一応参考までに普通の軍も準備されてもらったんです
けども
ちょっとパワー金でこっち月の5分です
[音楽]
同じほしいんですけど土居時量すごいなんか伸縮性がある東海ですねまぁとりあえず
この普通のゴムとバネの力の
この2つが実際にどれくらい違うかというのはまずは検証してみようと思いますが
こんなデカイの使って誰も分からないと思うんでを入れて挟んでこういうことになっ
ちゃいます
これ曲げると本ってなってね話すと飛ぶ
ん
こんなちょ違うなぜこの2つにここにその分がくっついててうにゃんでマイケルせめて
曲げてちょいぶっぱであるのわかります
このでパリをですねその装置に噛ませますですこのソースのこの穴に出っ張りを見れ
ます
自分の出っ張りをこのグリップで挟むそうするかまーす work not work
で挟みます
抑え込むとバッチリとバレット
いうことですっていうこと装置があるんですけどもちょうどなんか使って二つ入れる
ことができる
今回はこの2つを使ってですねどっちが高く飛ぶかどっちがその上に口から髪を目指す
力をっていうを目指す力
まあそういうのがどっち方があるかっていうのをちょっと本屋実験で試してみましょう
中のまにか本格的な実験みたいになってますけどもつい
あっあってなんておかしい早いでしょ
これじゃあもう一回もう一回言っておきましょうつい2
パンッ
[音楽]
はい今のでございますでしょうか潘家に大きな差があるということでございます
同じ com と思えない立場でこの逆さでございますルーサー
配球に今のでわかったと思いますこれがバネのチカラパワー誰でございますが
そんなのそれは終わらないぞなんという意味でいえばこちらにですねさっきのパワー
までも飛ぶ相当4つ準備してあるんですけども
この4つこう直列につないで飛ばすとさっきのパワーまでの伸びの旅4倍になると僕は
考えておりますよ
これなら僕にする2回を突き破って上への簡単な音簡易通路ができるというわけなんで
今後4つをとりあえずつなげてみよう
思いますはーい
うち4売れん
5皆さんこれらの提供品なんですけどぶち壊しています
ごめんなさいチラーをエラ骨ああ
オッシャーパー入っていうできましたこちらですね
ダーバン4倍の力ホテルソーズでございます尾根を飛ばせばとんでもないことになる
さっきいう使う4万いいですからね典座築き上げること間違いないと思ってますね
取り付けた俺の活動取り付けたら俺の勝ちで取り付けたらまたかずいぶんがんばれ
がんばれ
前田飛びたいんだろうホリデーんだろうことをとこ見せようぜ
嫁でがんばれがんばれバーム
[音楽]
5風です
図4隻ででしてねそれで我々の晴れ買うよ馬う必要じゃこれ
がんばねぇ誰だ何としてもつけるんだ1回つければも稼いだからなぁああああっすっ
げー
摂津いたできますついたかいきます3
プーマ
詰まっていますとっ
[音楽]
うわぁこんなとんでもでパワーも2パワー晴れという名の特殊なゴムがあるんですけど
もう今回俺が言いたかったのはなんと特殊な場合の力を使って頭を作るとどうなるか
んっていう話なんですよ
あああああこちらでございますスポーツシューズバネの力でございますちょっと
バレーの力って書いてあります
このスポーツ実は子どもたちの思いに応えるために開発されたムーンスター
スーパースターのバネのチカラ
最大の特徴ソウルに倒産しているパワーバネさっき見せたレジで土祝前滑ると特殊な
ゴムをは搭載している
米の反発力復元力から推進力を得る仕組みで速く走るための切り出しの力をサポートし
ているというわけでございますね小学校
時はさ葛利長は決まると思ってたから懐かしいなぁ
この声が入ってたよめっちゃ好き女どす正しいな妻スプリンターということでこちらが
それが場での使うの靴でございますめっちゃが付いんだけどこれもこんなに足が小さい
家があったんだよこの人のソール部分についているのが先ほど紹介したパワーバネで
ござる組み込むとパワーを貯めて減らすと
上手に住む力を推進力に変えるっていうくにゃっと曲がっていけど
イオン跳ね返るこれよってこうネットとちょっと生えて走れるということでございます
なんかねちゃんと調べている結果があるらしいんですけども1秒間数は子どもから大人
までほぼ一定ということでございますねホセは1秒からコスは一緒なんで
歩幅を残すバネの力で歩幅を動画
明日機能を開発したということでございますなるほどで実際に実験したところです
50m と馳せると想定した場合の場合の力によると何度50cm 早くゴールと
できるというふうにかけたらそうでござい
5位達勝負の世界はミリ単位のちまうぞこの50センチはかなりでかいと思いますその
反発術縮減曲ですねこれはこういう靴めっちゃ好きだったんですよ
そこの少年俺みたいに早くなりたいか
俺は別早いわけじゃないよ俺茶杯わけじゃないけども力をためて音と吐き出す力2の音
強いわけなんですよさっきの見たでしょ
普通のゴムとこの5分の使うのさあそれがですね届くとには搭載されているわけなん
ですよ軽いはカラーバリエーションもなかなか豊富でございます
なのでこの色好き各打者は3個ですね俺立つ人間が速く走るために開発された
バニの力というシューズの照明でございましたライバルに負けなくないだろライバルに
負けないためには
いっ
まあ練習しは含まれ編集も大事だけどもう少しでもスピードを縮めるためには足下から
しっかり入ることも同じだと思いますぜひ
ミュンスターさんとかバネのチカラとんでもない五分の力を秘めてるって思うので外で
走ることがある君ぜひ使ってみたかっていいと思います
じゃあ
ben ん
[音楽]